[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this is the
return of the incredible
one-of-a-kind brilliant hilarious Chris
gethard find out everything Chris is up
to including his tour dates at Chris
Geth
g-e-t-h.com you can also watch his most
recent special half my life on
comedydynamics.com I have to say I
hadn't seen Chris in a while and we I
mean this conversation blew me away it
was so fun so funny so interesting I'm
so glad that you're here to check it out
he is just like I said he's one of a
kind you are going to love it just a
word not of warning but if you don't
like two grown men talking Val Cameo if
you don't like if you're watching the
video if you don't like two grown men in
their 40s talking about poop and poop
strategies maybe skip the first five but
don't give up on this episode because it
is thoughtful it is interesting it is
inspiring and it is hilarious and let's
get to it as I always say as quickly as
possible the best way to support this
show if you want well first of all you
could see me on the road go to
petehomes.com I'm going to be in
Milwaukee coming up and then Madison
Wisconsin those shows are sold out which
is awesome thank you everybody there may
still be tickets available for Milwaukee
uh that should be the name of my book of
going on the road there may still be
tickets available in Milwaukee but all
the cities that I'm going to be in we're
adding new dates all of the time I
believe we just added Cleveland they're
all on petehomes.com I'm so proud of
this hour the shows have been great
please come out and see me if I'm coming
to a town near you petehomes.com
also you can try a Pete's pick these are
products that I actually use and
actually love like our friends at Living
Libations I'm I'm mindful about what I
put in my body but years ago I realized
I wasn't being careful about what I put
on my body which of course ends up in
your body I was buying shaving cream and
face washes that I thought were good
because they had fancy French names or
they would everybody seemed to be using
but of course these products are filled
with chemicals linked to disease and
toxicity levels never intended for human
consumption and I realized I want to eat
food where I recognize the ingredients
and I want my skin care to be the same
so enter living Libations not only the
best and most effective skin care hair
eyes teeth baby care products that I've
ever found but also the most natural
that means made exclusively with plants
and oils and extracts that not only will
you recognize but you'll be able to
easily pronounce and they work and
they're high end and they're gorgeous
and the packaging is nice and they are
effective and you'll be able to read it
and feel good about what you're putting
on slash in your body now that it's
summer having a natural zinc based
sunblock for Leela is so important and
so many of them that I found online
claim to be natural but they just aren't
just look a little closer for Woods that
have like nine consonants in a row and
and then a number that's not natural
just because there's zinc in it and 50
other chemicals doesn't make it natural
but there love the sun sunblock at
Living Libations not only works but we
feel great about putting on our baby and
ourselves all summer long and a little
goes a long way this is a great way to
support the show because you probably
have a face teeth Hair Skin eyes maybe
even a baby get something small get
something big whatever your skin needs
they have a premium natural and
wonderful product to replace the random
chemical nightmare that they sell at
7-Eleven so for 15 off and show your
support of the show go to
livinglibations.com weird
livinglibations.com weird and for those
of you watching the video you can see
you probably recognize I'm always
wearing my Apollo neuro if there is one
piece of tech that has changed my life
the most in the past years and valves
it's hands down been our Apollo neuros
Apollo neuro is a new wearable piece of
tech that helps your body recover from
stress by sending vibrations into your
body that gives your nervous system the
sensation of being touched or held
Apollo can help you relax sleep focus
and be more productive it's like a
wearable hug for the nervous system
using touch therapy to help you feel
safe and in control mine is running
right now and I love that I found this
it's like finding the fuse box for your
emotions for your feelings for your body
you open it up you can you can wear the
Apollo on your wrist or on your ankle
the settings are energy and wake up I
use it all the time especially when I'm
driving or if you don't want more coffee
social and open great for parties clear
and focus great for work rebuild and
recover great for after a workout or a
tense situation calm great for
meditation unwind great for the end of
the night when maybe you don't want to
have a cocktail or smoke something you
can let your body relax you with the
help of the Apollo and fall asleep I
mean a chemical free way to allow
yourself asleep or back asleep I use it
every single night Apollo neuro is not a
woo-woo product it's not a mood ring or
a crystal it was developed by a
neuroscientist and a board-certified
psychiatrist who've been studying the
impacts of chronic stress in humans for
nearly 15 years and the Apollo's effects
on stress sleep cognitive performance
and Recovery have been proven in
multiple clinical trials and real world
studies so give yourself a gift give
someone you love a gift that's
struggling with stress or over like we
all are and go to
apollonuro.com weird you'll get 10 off
that's APO
l-l-o-n-e-u-r-o.com slash weird is promo
code weird at checkout for 10 off show
your support for your body show your
support for this show all right
everybody so thrilled to be back with
Chris gethard get into it was that bad
no that was great I was saying hi yeah
but you kind of recoiled oh no well I
want to make sure my phone's on airplane
mode oh full airplane [__] yeah see if
you were really L.A you'd go do not
disturb oh is that the LA thing I just
feel like because then they could still
get you if they call you a bunch of
times right okay I like that I'm
complimenting that how do not disturb
works if you call multiple times but see
that you need to note that I think
there's an important call coming at any
point today when you know there's not no
like if I had it on if there was any
element of me that thought something
notable was going to happen then maybe
I'd leave it on do not disturb but
there's a I have nothing going on
I have nothing happening so I can go
full airplane mode
you know what I mean
no one's like hey
wait by the phone for a big time call
it's not happening
you know how I know Chris isn't doing
great he went airplane mode yeah your
life is airplane motable to put it in
perspective and this is true
we're doing this and then I'm going to
the airport so I can fly to Chicago to
sign autographs at an office fan
convention at an office fan two episodes
we just watched there you go uh and we
got I'm happy to divide it every time
you were on is that a thing that's
apparently a thing you've ever done that
before haven't done it and as you can
imagine I'm both like this should be
funny and interesting and it'll be nice
to meet some people and I'm also
deeply in my head about it too why
because the office was not my show well
yeah you're gonna have to there's a
certain there's two episodes of it and
I'm like oh
you know definitely one of those things
where I'm like oh they're paying they're
playing pretty good and I have a kid so
I guess I'll go do this thing that I
don't I wouldn't say that I'm people
don't think of the office and go yeah
that Chris cathard
vehicle I you know when we watched it
like so many we re-watched it recently
everybody's in a current state of
re-watching the office perpetually
that's what I mean I really think
there's like a it's a phenomenon it's
like a mass hypnosis or a mass
compulsion is actually I will say that I
would you know I was on two episodes
after Steve Carell left stop saying that
just no as your agent but to put it in
perspective and I know I know oh you're
saying and still I'm saying that I get
stopped for that more than anything else
yes in my career hey you're that guy
you're the guy who tried to say Oscar
with the pipe you score I I I you're
funny I I had a good moment I had a good
day on the set but I mean I've done
other things and you know like I hosted
a show on cable with my name on it for
three years no one brings that up the
office though so yeah based on me I
bring it up to say I was on those two
episodes after Corel left which yes
self-deprecating joke and I know you've
seen me do that too much in my life but
no no I just I bring it up to say like
so good can't imagine what
like the others were on from the
beginning today can you imagine being
Hey Kevin Malone you probably can't
leave his house that's what I mean yeah
from the looks of him I'm not gonna make
that joke he actually lost quite a bit
of weight oh wow yeah I saw him in a
commercial campaign but by the way
speaking of a a heavy joke that I
skipped that that show certainly doesn't
skip them
have you watched it it's jokes what do
you mean
jokes what are you saying I'm saying
they make a lot of fat jokes oh those
jokes they make a lot of fat jokes yeah
I wonder I wonder if they do that today
I wonder if they're ready you wouldn't
do it today I don't think yeah but they
were taking a note from the British
office certainly that did not shy away
the joke is that you shouldn't make that
joke right partly right and then at a
certain point and I'm not even mad at it
but they if somebody's heavy you have to
address it on the office in the world of
the office not just uh um Corel who is
the character that's supposed to be like
and you uh whoops yeah you know but
everybody by the end is like and Phyllis
God help us if Phyllis gets a look at
that Eminem it's gone you know and like
Craig Robinson got bigger they they had
to address it it was not just like hey
different bodies by the way this isn't
shots fired and I don't mean to put you
on the spot as a spokesperson but that
is something I notice I will say what do
you think of yes our boy Zach Woods have
you watched the whole office I have over
time I have you're not I feel like I've
absorbed it all but I haven't sat down
and been like we're on season six I see
it's more in like in the way that I
think just because it's on constantly
more like when I'm on the road it's on
in the hotel room all the time it's on
in the plane it's on the plane all the
time so I've picked it up I'm not
obsessive like the people I will be
meeting in Chicago this weekend that are
gonna say do you still have that pipe
and they're gonna reference things that
I don't even remember yeah because for
me it was two working days in my life
that I was flattered to do yeah but it
means something to people and that's
cool yeah you know who you are oh no no
no no
that by the way I opened with a roast
like I made fun of you because you were
on the phone saying like this kid's
great he's gonna be on SNL and I
remembered someone else who said that
about yes and I was like oh don't listen
to the Catherine so I opened in a roasty
way but that's not the energy I'm greedy
well you really nailed me you really
nailed me from my well-known habit of
trying to help younger Comedians and not
helping them
ultimately
I mean I'm not doubting I'm not I will
say I was gonna say by the way you're
Sam Rockwell in Galaxy Quest thank you
that's hyper that's a great move but all
it is a great it's a perfect movie and
also he's the guy that was only on a
couple episodes but he goes to the
conventions wasn't mean to you it's just
no I get it okay so tell only because
it's nice to talk about these things
yeah who do you remember helping who
because you helped me you can include me
on that list for sure I think there were
a bunch of people along the way I will
say like you know the gether show is
this thing in my life that I look back
on it and even I now have to half the
episodes I'm like oh rethinking and my
name was on it I would never do that
today but I thought that recently too
because I did your show yeah and I saw a
clip because of the internet what a
great thing yeah well we had a childish
Gambino because of the internet the
internet because the internet I we
washed our butts on your shoes yeah we
had bidets set up in front of a live
studio audience into our butts and for
everyone that was there yeah they were
there but I was there and I felt my
butthole getting squashed yeah wet
squashed like not a splash not a squish
but a squash you don't have a long
history of talking about butt stuff you
and I yeah well the last time we do the
show we talked about eating ass and I
did have one question now that you're
married and have a kid I'm gonna guess
it's on the menu less
astute astute observation I also feel
like one of our early bonding things
attitude uh boom boom one of our early
bonding marketing because you know every
if they've heard me on the show before
they know I touch you in a class and
then you were I think put me up on my
second stand-up show ever is that right
I forgot that part yeah and uh the
second time I ever did stand up was a
show that you you were like I know
you're trying to do it come do it but
also in the midst of that at one point I
got a colonic and you found out about
that and you loved that I got a colonic
and I just loved that you got it you
wanted to know everything about the
colonic and we remember the store the
line
no there's a pull quote from your
colonic story I don't mean on stage I
mean in real life and it was this and I
don't think you're gonna mind you said
oh maybe you'll mind maybe we'll edit
this out I don't know but you said I
didn't know I wanted to diarrhea on a
nurse's hand yeah but it turns out I did
yeah I didn't I've never imagined how
good it would feel to just let loose
onto a woman's beautiful hands
it's just like but it was her job and
she was like and she was guiding me
through it and she was coaxing me she
was figuring out almost like uh now that
I it's like being a baby it's like being
a baby I was just gonna say I was in the
room for my son's birth and I'm not
going to compare it at all but it's the
closest I've ever had yeah that's right
yeah this woman was like come on ease up
loosen those stomach muscles let it go
it's okay so I I have gloves on
everything's fine you can do this I
wasn't for those of you who haven't had
a clonic it's when something is inserted
in your butt it's only the size of a
pencil that's what they tell you you
remember this because yeah I went to the
same place you went to the place I went
I think I got it first you got it first
I think I got it first
city I was on their mailing list for
years I finally unsubscribed it sounds
like a company that makes like the chip
that goes in the Terminator robots I
felt like I told you about it that feels
right but I think it's possible it went
the other way in a gmail search away
somebody told somebody I'm sure yeah but
I think I okay whoever did it first I've
gotten them since you'll never go to a
place that
pooping is the thing that you don't want
to do in front of someone else yeah I
[__] in my pants yeah like I don't even
love their guys at the airport
businessman I'm assuming
blasting uh they can't wait I don't even
fart at urinals I I understand that it's
a it's a gray area well it's a dangerous
game too
you never I never farted a urinal
because that because it might let loose
I always once had a punk rock show in
high school and a friend of mine farted
at a urinal and [__]
ever since then I said that's the most
dangerous game not hunting not in
hunting man for sport no no
when you [__] your pants and you're four
feet away from an unoccupied toilet
because you had the hubris you had the
hubris to fart standing up I'm gonna who
do you think you are I'm gonna say you
get you what you deserve oh absolutely I
get it in any court of law
a judge would side with the guy who
farts in the in the in the because I
could hear every guy that does it I can
hear him going we're in the bathroom
yeah if I was in there it would be okay
and I'm like but you're not in there
there is where you're covered your shame
is covered I don't have to see your face
I don't see your face I don't want to
see the face of he who farts the
Metallica see we we uh I would say I'm
not offended like I don't think it's a
faux pot like and you're loosening up a
lot of the muscles in that region so if
a fart comes out I get it that I like
but I hear the worst ones I hear like
Miles Davis high notes those people will
they will stop that behavior because
that's something because at some point
life will teach you how old was your
punk rock friend that was blasting uh
we were in high school that's too young
to be [__] yourself at a urinal yeah
now
it's okay now you're not even surprised
you're like well I had it coming
I'll ask you since we're on this topic
and people are probably already like
they got here already they're triple
this went we didn't even answer you were
like who are some comedians you've
helped and instead we've just dwelled on
we'll get to how you've been an angel
I'm in my 40s is it normal to have to
[__] 24 hours a day seven days a week is
it normal to just always feel like you
have a [__] and they're in a special
place because I'm going to tell you
something again I've never talked about
this yeah can you relate to the idea
that you could [__] in your 40s I could
[__] but I'm gonna let it congeal a
little more I'm gonna leave it in the
Kiln see for me I needed to fire more
because it'll come out in like a huge
like one installment or I could have a
bag of Skittles right now little deer
shits
like I'll literally go I like to relate
to you yes I could almost at any time
but I'm like this one needs to stay in
the oven it needs 350. happy says 60
more minutes I've had that and I've had
the companion thing of have you ever had
it where you're like
I'm just gonna I guess I'm just gonna
get off the toilet because like at some
point I have to do something else today
it has to be done I gotta do something
else today so I guess I'll just walk
around with the rest of this [__] in my
butt even though I know it's still there
okay because a phone because of phones
sometimes you poop and you're done but
you want to finish your Wordle or you
want to finish your scroll or whatever
it is you want to avoid the
responsibilities of Life yeah facts and
you sit because you're already seated
yeah and then you poop again yeah and
then you go and you look at it you're
like oh my God so if I hadn't been on my
phone I just would have been walking
around with that that was in my grocery
bag yeah you think about I never think
but that was you it was with you yeah
and sometimes I'm in a terrible mood and
I poop and I'm like everything's better
now
like I thought I was sick or I thought I
was afraid of the universe sure turns
out I just had to poo poo yeah 24 hours
a day seven days a week I could
right now if we took a break right now I
could show it to you before I flashed
thousand percent confident in that and
by the way I'm certain of it now yeah
that's most hours of the day and you're
saying most of your poos you're just
abandoning meaning you're going I'm
ending this like you end
a series you're binging
like you you see next episode in 15 and
you're like I'm gonna call this a night
I've heard that directors sometimes have
the attitude of like the movies never
finished it just has to come out yeah
it's abandoned and that's that's how you
feel about yourself that's how I feel
about my bowel movements in my 40s
I'm loving this I have noted that Katie
a younger woman is just not not I'm not
judging I'm like I'm dying with
relatability it's a yes
don't talk to me about fiber go ahead
well I buy it I and then I find I
realize at some point oh I didn't commit
to it now it's just taking up too much
space in the cabinet
okay I have a couple thoughts one you
can get gummies that have fiber in them
and that's like candy yeah which yeah
I'm saying if the if the choice is
eating candy and getting fiber or not
getting any fiber let's go with the
candy and fiber you can also take it in
pills I I've also started putting it in
my smoothie psyllium husky in my
smoothie it makes it a little thicker
yeah but when you sit down Pam and you
and no wipe necessary and get one of
them
I had a friend who used to call them
white Glovers if you were in a tux with
white gloves on you could just
wipe your butt and you wouldn't see a
mark you sometimes you're so confident
you're like I know and you just wanna I
wouldn't you know me well enough to know
I've never been so confident about
anything but sometimes you're like I'm
just gonna wipe as a courtesy just a
scoreboard you do always see that this
is an A plus you do always give it you
know it is it's a white glove in that
you're done you pull up your drawers and
you want your assistant to double tap a
cane on the ground to alert you that
he's about to throw it to you so it and
then he tosses it and you catch it and
you go I get no kick from Champagne
alcohol doesn't thrill me at all so tell
me why should it be true who's toilet
paper on your shoe I have toilet paper
on my which is the in the inverse of the
Eternal wipe
we are like I've pooped for 40 seconds
and I've been wiping for nine minutes
what's happening can I tell you my
solution to the Eternal wipe and look I
get it we're talking poop I'm loving it
okay most people are listening to this
in their car anyway you know what I mean
or on the treadmill it's a little secret
that's really weirdos in each of their
ears talking poops yeah they're not
bored you do a little cardio that'll
break it up yeah that helps cardio helps
for sure it helps with everything yeah
um I nuke it what does nuke it mean uh
you get a big old ball of toilet paper
and you go and you go
and that's going to be a mess but the
next one's gonna be fine okay nuke it
can I tell you you abandoned you've been
in all sense of decorum in that in that
wipe just a big and back and forth
vigorous like like cleaning uh Barnacles
off a ship
like a power wash a power wash yeah and
look should I be ashamed maybe should I
keep that to myself perhaps will you do
it and go God damn it it works yeah all
right and you'll be grateful to try it
and you're like better I'm also a fan of
the pinch
go in from the front and don't wipe
pinch here's your butthole
pinch much cleaner much better okay the
pinch give it a Google too I didn't make
it up
are you regretting saying yes to this
show I would just say that I would say
that if you saw a moment of regret I
would say if you look at the writer's
room from the gether show I helped a lot
of good people and I'm proud of it
going back you're going back you want
some you launched some Rockets I
wouldn't say I launched them I would say
that the thing I was always really proud
about of myself in New York comedy was
uh
I tended to have a sense of
like this person's interesting and good
and if I can help him out a little bit
on their way to something I would never
take credit but like yeah I believe Joe
firestone's first writing job yeah Julio
Torres is second Anna fabrega yeah Will
Miles who's great like so so many people
have passed through yeah that's great I
think the first time Joe perro was on TV
was my public access show Conor O'Malley
I think his first time on TV okay some
people were I'm like those are cool
people and I I saw it and I knew 80 of
them let me say but I'm out of the loop
man there you go to Indiana because
we're out of the loop oh it's like I
moved out to Chicago I understand you
got it yeah the loop oh I forgot you're
one of our finest Minds do you ever get
your you are do you ever get your heart
broken because I do
helping I'm a helper too yeah I love
helping this could get dark fast I don't
want to get dark if you want to keep it
positive well yeah well I'm very what
are you you're like a vampire and you go
don't carrying my parlor I have to go in
the Parlor now I know you I knew what I
was doing there
we've known each other a long time I
just mean I it's actually beautiful let
me say it in the beautiful way I care I
care about my people and zoom out far
enough we're all my people but comedians
specific kind of freaky deakis we deal
with a lot of anxiety sometimes people
are like why didn't you reply to my
email and I'm like you don't know how it
feels to quote Tom Petty I'm Free
Falling yeah that was a joke because it
was already you don't know how it feels
like me no yes kind of two jokes
I'm gonna Pat that instead of you
um
so oh there's an old used tissue in
there Julia Louis Dreyfus really yeah is
that true would you like it she stuck it
in there and you just remember the last
one here we're gonna leave that forever
that stays
that stays DNA
jld DNA
I knew there was a bet this is a day off
man this is a day off I'm having a great
time good so I care like you care and
sometimes I get my heart broken there's
a fine line between everyone has to do
it like I do it I sound like an old man
and then there is I'm an old man I just
am an old man there are things that are
proven in Show Business to help
and those things can be bestowed and
sometimes they're adhered and sometimes
they're not and when they're not I do
get sad I think about a lot Mulaney said
this on on the Pod and I think about all
the time he goes in every photograph in
every Comedy Club a black and white
photograph Robin Williams Whoopi
Goldberg let's say Dan aykroyd's there
for some reason in the middle there's
always one guy nobody could follow Lenny
nobody could follow Lenny Robin Williams
like oh here's the king he told me
everything right and like who is Lenny
I'm not saying everybody needs to be
successful or famous or Rich even it
just sort of pains me when I go [__] man
Lenny it's a it's a recurring phenomenon
like re-watching the office every scene
every generation has at least three four
five of these people that you're just
like what was it and what hurts me about
it is I'm like is often anxiety
substance abuse uh or just a a
fuzziness that the American capitalistic
system doesn't gel with them it's
actually part of what makes them
beautiful you know what I'm saying but
then when you put them in a showcase
situation they lock up that's not what
they were built for does that make sense
totally does I would also say and I feel
like you might disagree with this can't
we
but there's some part of me as I've
gotten older as well that goes maybe
those people
were healthy enough
to realize the madness to realize I
there's another way I can be happy and
if I can be happy another way I think
maybe I should go do that because
there's a lot of unhappiness and it's
sad to realize that that doesn't stop
okay I didn't realize I was eating the
most delicious ice cream because we just
uncovered a swirl I thought it was
Vanilla but there's a delicious gathered
swirl maybe maybe Lenny like went and
got a day job with a retirement plan
yeah and has three kids and can we say
and Lenny's great and this is the other
part of the conversation
I could give you a longer list so
there's Lenny's five lennies in every
scene let's say there's ten we'll call
them malcolms there's ten malcolms of
those malcolms let's say malcolms are
comedians that are working
that we probably know of right yeah a
lot of them are [__] miserable yeah
miserable yeah so I love what you're
saying because I don't think a lot of
people pause and say why why do I want I
want to be a successful Community why
the answer is always to be happy the
answer is always if I'm famous I'll be
happy if I'm rich if I'm fulfilled
artistically I'll be happy yeah and if
Lenny went wait I'm happy when this this
and this and that's beautiful
uh my friend just told me about Jonathan
Winters when he retired he would go on
these little walks he'd go into his
hardware store and crack everybody up
he'd crack up all the ladies on the bus
on the bus bench and he was like that's
all I need if I had known it turns out
that's all I need that's a Lenny right
I mean to be fair four out of five
lennies are probably like
you know dying alone in a gutter let's
get the round po
one of those five might just go be like
a happy well-adjusted person and I and
I'm happy for those people because there
is that's not a tragic tale I agree it's
more tragic
to
not never know how to give up the chase
when the chase
is depleting you it turns out the chase
caught up to you right like you were you
are you chasing the Chaser is the chase
chasing you it chased you like you were
chasing a dream right because you wanted
to pounce on its back right but it
lapped you on this little The Little
Prince tiny planet and it came behind
you and collapsed you and we live in a
world I actually look I don't I'm not
this is not shots fired but when I
watched the underdog win an Oscar which
happens almost every year it's like a
thing and they go don't give up on your
dreams
I it it does bug me a little bit it's
it's do you know what I mean by that I
do I I'm not I'm not the guy that says
give up on your dreams but I'm like I
always say follow the dream that's
following you you get feedback right
you're doing well you're getting laughs
it feels right but when you're just
going like be famous win an Oscar look
at work for me that's like the guy going
like
I ate only lemons and it cured my you
know sciatica right and I'm like it's
not it's not totally it's not
reproducible and it's not totally
responsible but it's it's not I also
don't want to yuck that person's yum in
their moment of Victory I would do the
same thing I I am the same thing I by
the way I was just thinking my daughter
yucks my um every morning really and I I
want like when am I gonna teach her
don't yuck someone's yum so it's weird
that you said that I totally agree I
would do the same thing
I've been saying this phrase lately if I
were you I'd be you
does that do you get the piece of that
explain
if I were you it's the most basic thing
yeah if I were Chris gethard if I were
born with your brain your family your
body your life I would be you it's true
but do you see the peace in that like
when someone's someone you don't
understand your mom your dad whoever
pick your enemy if you have an enemy if
I were that might be them yeah you would
be doing what they're doing and if I won
an Oscar and I was an underdog I would
get up there and go like never stop
believing holy [__] it worked it worked
and it'll work for you it will work like
into camera it will work for you don't
quit for sure and I can see the part
that's like is that is that helpful I
have a thought a very informed thought
it's in my joke notebook as one of those
like sentence fragments like a poop that
needs to stay in 30 more minutes
but um I had the thought recently that I
think you'll like in this context of
like
I think the most dangerous
the dangerous phrase like one of the
more dangerous phrases in all of
literature is then they lived happily
ever after that's like the biggest
narrative cop out since it was all a
dream
because you just end and it's like no no
like yeah the hero ends in that moment
like the Oscar speech but like in two
years
well I don't know what are they gonna be
doing I don't know 5 and 10 and 15. and
I'm I feel that there are people that
famously there was a cinematographer
that killed himself the year after he
won an Oscar
because that's a whole other
challenge you did the thing that
everybody was telling you you should do
the dread pirate Roberts got princess
Buttercup guess what new adventure she's
a loud chewer
right you know what I mean right as you
wish they got turns out you never had a
meal with her and she's a loud chewer
guess what like 30 months later they got
in a fight over curtains you know that's
right
pirate Robert I still I still sometimes
have this sad thought where I'm like I'm
not suicidal anymore but I do sometimes
sit here and I go I'm turning 43 this
year and I might need to double that
and that's so annoying yes like why did
Med why did they get medicine working so
I gotta double this yeah Nanobots are
gonna clean your feelings everything
cool is
coming gone now this is good we could
unpack that but I hear you
professionally now my kid is a game
changer and has rearranged my priorities
in a lot of ways as well which is great
but I do sometimes have that thing of
like
43 and I gotta double this I'm gonna be
so tired I completely understand so long
I'm so with you on the drive-in today
yeah I thought I could see myself saying
the Val dying is the best thing I've
ever done like as I'm like slowly going
out because think about it no more
emails yeah you email me sorry I'm dying
I don't even reply yeah you'll just see
on Instagram sure oh I guess he was
dying gone no more phone calls no more
bills no more teachers no more books let
me put this past yet a dark thought that
I would not say to most people I already
agreed with you on the idea that death
could be a relief no because you've
known me forever yes and you knew me
when I was like
a semi-tragic figure in New York as far
as people being like that guy's great
and all his friends are getting jobs and
he's not you were there for that stretch
you were witness yes but I thought you
were the coolest in fact whenever I
think about you I think of how I said
thinking I was complimenting you you're
the best teacher I hope you're doing
this for 10 years and you said
immediately like you're gonna give me
like a [__] panic attack shut up
something like that you said don't curse
me yeah and I was shocked yeah because I
thought you were like Mr Holland's Opus
like I I was like this guy knows it
turns out I had my own dreams too of
course but I thought like a teacher you
must live at the school and you must
like teaching yeah and I do yeah
sometimes teaching I miss teaching more
than I miss doing improv by far I would
say so keep going it's a tragic figure I
was there
sweating it out
it was fun stressful and then I got some
success came and went
at the public access show Mr punk rock
why is he doing it this way turned into
the cable show been on some things HBO
special like
I've written five books at this point
I'm in my 40s well
that's more than one a decade have you
heard the phrase because it'll make you
feel good everyone has one book in them
almost nobody has two look at that
almost nobody nobody has four yeah and
two of them are good keep going there
you go just 100 JK it's weird no but
here's the thing is like
I live in New Jersey that's a choice yep
that's on the license plate by the way
here's your choice it's a choice it's a
great joke
anybody who knows me knows I have like a
real wariness with engaging with the
industry of wariness of it always have
some of that's probably rooted in some
self-sabotage self-confidence issues
some of it is also though
like do I wanna
fight very hard to excel in a field
where there's so many bad things
happening like there are parts of me
going like I don't know you know on what
level you know like I know but your
weinsteins your Cosby's your people
getting cornered and witnessing sexual
that's why my mind went too as well but
I would also take the shallowness the
greed
the ego asking asking someone how
they're doing and their answer is a list
of projects that they have coming up
where I just go I can't it's a I can't
feel okay and I'm not judging an
indigenous person would have on
Ayahuasca they'd be like I saw a
horrible future right yeah I get it and
uh and it's it's hard for me to keep up
with it and hard for me to want to but
I do think because I you know
I haven't had as much relevance in the
past years as I used to when I was like
Mr New York underground guy um
but I am like
man like I put out a lot of stuff now
and I'm fighting hard to gain traction
on it and that's part of the gig and
that's fine
but when I die
I do feel like there's gonna be a thing
of people being like this guy was making
cool stuff the whole time and I'm like
alive now and I'm like oh but people
aren't noticing it but I know I know I'm
gonna have a cooler obituary they'll
like me when I'm dead they're gonna like
me like my obituary in the articles are
gonna be a lot cooler than my life
currently feels that's a huge Epiphany
so Eckhart Tolle says the way you feel
about the way you feel right now right
now not a little later now that we'll
feel this now yeah the way we feel right
now and everyone listening
is how you feel about your life
woof
but look at the possibility let's let's
tweak the levels let's get some
gratitude going let's get to like all
the things you're dreading belonging to
A system that hurts so many people
belonging to A system that can suck your
soul for lack of a better metaphor
belonging to a system where I once had
to push pitch a TV show to a uh DJ in a
neon hatch
that one this was after my show got
canceled and I had a pitch in my buddy
my butt I told my I told my buddy I was
I'm pitching the show and he goes where
and I told him where and he goes with
who and I told him who he goes I've
pitched that guy goes have you ever seen
his Instagram I go no he goes look at it
he's a DJ like his Instagram is all
about how he's a DJ and I went and I'm
not going to judge DJ's Network
executive Anna DJ he's a network
executive who his Instagram was just all
his DJing gigs and then he entered the
pitch and he was wearing a neon hat and
when I tell you on what pink and when I
tell you that I I
as I walked out I was like I bombed that
and I knew I was bombing it
I couldn't I couldn't for my own
self-esteem pitch not even I can pitch
to anybody I don't care how old you are
I don't care your experience
but I can't I can't
this was also a person who immediately
behaved in a way where I could tell
his attitude was why should I grant you
my validation and I can't with that I
can't with that you can't with that with
anybody I couldn't with that with Steven
Spielberg with Scorsese I wouldn't want
to validate myself I would feel
desperate let alone yeah a DJ
If the DJ and the neon had had great
ideas and wanted to contribute to my
idea or had constructive criticism about
like here's why I don't think this is
totally but to go tweet and do that yeah
if the DJ and the neon hat is like I've
got 15 minutes I'm like no I have 15
minutes yes I understand we have
different [__] you I won't do what you
tell me is yeah um and that mine is I'll
live 3000 miles away from the heart of
the entertainment industry and then move
deeper into New Jersey when it's time
that's my [__] you I won't do what you
told me and I get it yeah and I want to
talk about that and I I just in
solidarity
yeah that's is this for me yeah I'm
gonna drink this Nirvana Water as HPV
hmb did you say it has HPV HPV no hmb it
did sound that you I did I did say it
wrong you said it you briefly said this
had genital warts no I said hmp I think
I thought you said HPV we all heard that
no hmb prevents muscle loss so enjoy
that well I've yeah I mean anything
keep this checked frame and vitamin D3
you're not a friend of the sun drink
that up
drink that up this is designed for you
feel super
um okay what was I gonna say oh my [__]
you I won't do what you tell me is
actually clean comedy because I spent
and I I'm only putting this back to you
I spend so much of my life thinking that
if I didn't swear and was nice I was
holy so now when I see and I love all
these guys Gaff again bargatsi like
figuring out clean comedy so why doesn't
old homesick most people think I'm a
clean comedy comedian anyway why not go
after that nut you know and I literally
mean that like as a business decision
not an artistic decision just a business
decision I could sell more tickets if I
was 100 clean then I get in touch with
my [__] you I want my gathered and it's
that wound and I'm wondering what yours
is my wound is I'm not gonna fake it I'm
not gonna pretend like life isn't
confusing I'm not gonna let you believe
that I was pure so you can continue
diluting yourself that you're pure I
would rather you go he was filthy or or
you know
not filthy you know what I mean he was
complicated and flawed and messy and
Afraid and angry and everything and he
wasn't ashamed that's my gospel I'm on
stage and I go no project yourself on me
because I know every nun every whatever
holy person in the car sometimes goes
[__] this guy [__] his stupid face
and I want you to go it's okay you're
okay and that's my [__] you I won't do
what you tell me and it comes from my
churchy piety where does your nobody's
gonna tell me I'm valuable to come from
or did that make you what did that make
you think
well I mean I have my
see I
I walk a line
where I go
there are a number of things that I've
Drawn Lines on
in an effort to have some level of
integrity
it feels important to me
sometimes it feels like no one else
cares so I sit there and go why do I do
it I'm making my life harder do it for
the obituary yeah like am I doing this
to feel good about myself you know when
I think about things like
I'd like to play venues that are all
ages instead of 21 plus I'd like to play
venues that don't have Ticketmaster so
people can avoid those fees I I like to
you know things like that where I go oh
that just means I make a little less
money or it means I have to do more of
the leg work but I have that goal in
mind and and even things like
just the general broad Strokes of it I
sit here I go there are some things that
I don't participate in
that have
made it feel like I sweat money more
because
yep it's easy and I sit here and go you
don't need to Franco yourself well but I
sit here and I go is that because of
some Integrity that I have which is
something to be proud of
or
am I convincing it
am I convincing myself that's what it is
because I don't have confidence
a self-love thing that we already talked
about self-love self not self-sabotage
like the opposite of self-sabotage is
for lack of a better word self-love
because it's not even love is almost
like the wrong word it's like
self-appreciation self tolerance
my guess is I think better than even
better than more accurate than self-love
so which is it are you doing it because
of this flaw and then going back and
changing the narrative to make yourself
more comfortable couldn't relate more
right I will say though as someone who
doesn't have those issues
I I talk to fans sometimes and they're
like yeah our tickets were 300 and I was
like just because it got bounced I don't
know why scalpers or whatever something
maybe I could have Chris gether did and
made sure that [__] doesn't have I don't
know I don't know if you can stop
someone from buying tickets and
reselling them but what I'm saying is
these things come at a cost I'm not
making those considerations and
sometimes I'll give you an example I was
reading
the Eightfold Path of Buddhism just a
little summary of it this morning and it
was like thoughts like being clear in
your thoughts and your actions and when
I saw livelihood I got a little twinge
in my stomach because I was like am I
being as pure as I could be so it's not
free you know what I mean there is
another
there's just another cloud in your
Consciousness potentially and the cloud
Reigns money and that's that's that's
nice you know
yeah sometimes sometimes it does yeah it
I don't mean not as much as it used to
like I had a stretch where the money was
coming in and I really slowed things
down some sometimes intentionally for
certain sometimes where I would go oh I
took a swing and a miss and I it had
been a while it had been there was a
stretch where if I did something like it
would get a little press in New York it
would get a little bit like here's what
he's up to now you know like those days
if he's on the Move yeah there was a
little bit of that I had a Anthony
DeVito Anthony DeVito who's a friend of
mine he's a comedian in New York really
great guy he he made me laugh the other
day he was like he was like uh we were
in Edinburgh together last year and he
said something that made me very proud
where he was like yeah for a lot of my
time in New York comedy it's like here's
the club scene here's the alt scene I
know there's an uptown scene who's
coming out of that scene then there's
also like whatever [__] gethers up
too off in that corner and that was like
a little slot that I occupied yeah I
thought he was gonna say the gethard
scene there was a little scene you know
there was a little I had my own little
corner of it and now you guys do that
really
I know we talked about this last time
but remember you were like I remember
you announced you were gonna do a class
I think about it all the time and you're
like and we're gonna decide what we're
gonna do and we're gonna do something
that's impossible yeah that's the most
gether thing and it worked and it worked
yeah I don't remember what it was it was
a class that we
the whole idea of the class was like
where are you coughing because you don't
I I like Andy finding I'm not huge I I
have issues no I had like an obsessed my
whole high school college life I was
like Andy confidence the best I just
don't feel the same there's a wickedness
right to Andy right there's an
antagonistic side of it I see you being
more like
life is is absurd let's let's let's give
it back what it's giving us well what I
took from him is
he was one of those people that it was
always funny and it also made you feel
something else too yeah like a new mommy
and with him it was yes like a new mommy
but with him it was often like you're
gonna be laughing really hard but you
might actually be pissed yeah or you
might actually be scared or confused
like these unsettling feelings right and
I think I really loved that idea of like
I want it to be funny but I also might
want to make them feel
something else along the way and a lot
of a lot of when I was at my best a lot
of it I think that was where the Kaufman
showed up right and what was the
impossible thing so that was a class I
mean I basically
as you know back in those days improv
classes usually capped at 16 people and
my basic idea was let's remove anything
about
improv that feels arbitrary and see
what's on the other side of it so this
idea that there's 16 people in a class
like that's a that's a space and time
and accounting issue right yeah so I was
like I'm just gonna take anyone who's
who seems like motivated and good so I
said just write me like here's an email
address write me an email why you want
to be in the class and then people wrote
and a lot of them were people who were
very good and who explained and then
there was a few a handful of people who
I'd never heard of one of whom was had
just gotten out of a level two class
but wrote this from an AOL email address
clearly signed it with a nickname not a
real name
and all it said was like um it was like
I have to be a part of this uh tell me
who I have to fight
and I could just tell her something I
said this person's joining the class
they had just gotten out of level two
and were threatening to fight everybody
anyone else so we wound up with 27 maybe
what else would go this is not not only
did I let him in the class I was later
the Reverend at his wedding and he was
the Reverend at mine it was my friend
Murph who was one of my Sidekicks on the
gethard show I could sense from the
email or something special about this
guy wow how did he sign up what's that
remember what was the nickname Murph his
real name's not Murph oh he just wrote
Murphy yeah m-u-r-f and I was like
whoever this guy is he's in so we had 27
people in and they're all it's a 27
person classes the whole thought was
like how does this work let's look at
every piece of how it happens and ask
why and then we'll decide if we need it
so like come out and get a suggestion
why do we do that we do that to just
start generating some content and
probably to prove to the audience that
it's improvised right right and to build
a bridge between you and them yeah are
there other ways to do that or is that a
thing that's totally necessary or
you know like how many people are in a
show usually eight why well that's
probably because of the size of a stage
in Chicago back in the day right yeah
yeah everyone can get enough speaking
time and there's enough room like that
probably related to the size of a
theater a Herald is generally 30 minutes
long why will that speak for an audience
what well what if you get a suggestion
and there's one person out of these 27
that has a 45 second monologue
and we all listened to it and go that
was really inspired great black it out
that's the show tonight if it's a better
show can we all put aside that 26 of us
didn't get to speak and can we weather
the storm that the audience paid five
bucks and only saw a 45 second show are
we willing to stand by that and say that
was the best version of the show and you
got your five dollars you know like or
is it going to be a four hour long show
why does that suggestion led to so much
stuff to dissect why should a podcast
this is my version why should a podcast
be 60 minutes right I don't understand I
started asking why does the show take
place in the theater well because the
audience needs to know where to go yeah
well okay that's a pretty valid reason
why does it have to stay there then like
right and these weren't questions I was
asking them these were questions that we
all were generating as a group then we
got to these um class shows that I was
really proud of and this was many many
years this was 2008 2009 before I I
largely left improv but
did a series of shows that I watched
um
and the whole idea was that everybody
came out and sat in the front row we
taped out the front row because it was
like why does everybody stand on stage
because they're part of the show well
what if you don't want to be a part of
the show tonight or what if the show
doesn't necessitate you we're not going
to start with everybody how do you go
questions right you're really uncovering
the like the movie Don't Think Twice how
we all have a Keegan Michael Key's
character in us that we're like I'm here
to steal the light right and take it
right you know what I mean and I want to
kill harder so I get SNL and you're like
what if it's just for the show very
interesting yeah there was a lot of that
and and a lot of the people in that
class were great and have have gone on
to a lot of success which I again don't
take any credit for Beyond
I I was always pretty good at getting a
bunch of good people together boxing out
some space where they could experiment
so the performer sat in the front row
yeah and was it in the theater it
started in the theater there were some
nights where they took the whole
audience outside with them very uncommon
a little bit yeah they're very Steve
Martin it's one show where I remember
it's actually funny maybe because we
just mentioned him he was on my mind
maybe my favorite show was uh and I
think you would love this whatever
happened the suggestion happens some
people started going out and speaking
and it somehow turned into some people
talking about like things they always
wanted to do as a kid and never have and
haven't done yet
and you know some of those I'm
forgetting the exact specifics but just
like
an example people being I've never been
off of the North American continent I
have to correct that this and that and
then Murph walks out
Murph was also in a phase of life where
every day he wore a white button down
with a black tie every day every day
like almost a manzukas a little close
um but when he started doing my public
tax this show someone once called up and
started making fun of him calling him
the Reservoir Dog which I thought was
the best just the best I also would have
gone Mormon the more so there you go
there you go but Reservoir Dog a hundred
times better so dude so Murph just walks
out on stage and murph's a bigger guy
and he's like a he's a gravel voice guy
he's a drinker and a smoker and like if
you saw him you'd go that dude looks
like you know he's one of those
broad-shouldered Guy where you're like
that guy probably throws back a whiskey
and you're right that guy in kielbasa
and he walked out on stage in in the
context of a comedy show and he was like
there was a kid in my neighborhood
growing up who could do a standing
backflip
and I thought it was the coolest thing
in the entire world
and I've never told anyone this but when
I was a kid I said I'm gonna do that
someday and I think about it and it's I
still remember the feeling of like how
cool I thought it would be if I could do
it and I've never done it and I've never
even actually tried and tonight on stage
I just I'm gonna do a standing back flip
and he's just like bigger out of shape
guy I need you can feel the whole crowd
is like no no no no no no no no no no no
no he's like no I'm gonna do it and then
it's like other people in the class it's
no longer an improp show it's people
going like dude like like you you yeah
really it's gonna be really bad like
having this discussion on stage nobody's
playing characters one guy walks that
beat he's like he goes let's dude Matt
Mayer great guy great guy really great
guy
um walks out he's like Murph he's like I
was the mascot in my high school
um like he used to wear the he's like a
Night Train he was like I trained as a
gymnast
do you really want to do this because
it's hard I've done it it's hard and
murph's like I gotta try and everyone
knew Murph enough to dude here's
so many tangents
I thought the gymnast was gonna be like
you can't do this you can't oh he
straight up was like like it's not
difficult he was like you're the
Kool-Aid man you're gonna flip and smash
it became this really gripping thing for
the audience I was up in the tech Booth
watching the whole thing and it became
this really gripping thing where it was
like
what do you do when a person says no I'm
gonna try
and then he this kid Matt stepped him
was like well I've done it and it's hard
and I don't think you can do it yeah but
I know you and if you're really gonna
try and he starts going Murph the main
thing this is dude a a show that an
audience has come to a comedy theater
for he's like
when you're doing a backflip no he
starts dude now he's the threat he's the
guy giving the tip is now the he's like
the Joker when you go to do a backflip
your body thinks something really wrong
is happening
so the whole trick is he said he's like
he's like the whole trick is
your body's gonna want to correct but
it's not a thing you've done so your
body doesn't know how to correct so you
have to mentally be strong enough to
tell your legs to keep following the
momentum you sent them in even though
your body wants to bail your body
doesn't want this to be happening your
instincts so you have to mentally
correct your own instincts merch like
all right all right and dude these
conversations go on and the whole
audience is just like what is happening
there's like some small moments of
tension relief but the credit not to me
to this class these 27 people never felt
any need to be like
but before that let's take break for a
character like none of it right you know
just like this nobody came out and was
like oh do you have a friend who's at
risk of doing a background right let's
do a commercial parody If you get
injured in an improv show call 1-800
[__] my face you know like none of that
it's all there none of that [__] slow
hanging you know and and we've all done
it we've all seen it and dude he
eventually [__] tried
and he went up
it didn't even make it a third of the
way through the rotation and came down
on his head and neck and then he's just
laying on the stage
and the whole room went completely
silenced and I was in the tech booth and
I was like I've killed a man
he signed up
he just got out of level two and now
he's dead because I thought it was cool
to remove all the rules and I had this
brief 10 second window where I was like
a man is dead
and people paid to watch it people paid
five dollars to come and watch anything
he killed himself
the Reservoir Dog the rest of our dog is
dead he's dead
he's dead on stage
and we were there to watch the crunch
it was a comedy show he leapt from the
building that was himself he tried to
and I thought it was really beautiful in
a way because and then he started moving
again thank you
and the crowd felt this relief and then
but then the rest of those 26 people
attacked the comedy show sight of it
after that and it was huge laughs and
all this adrenaline and energy and you
know almost I would argue like a little
bit of like oh you took a different drug
tonight you know what I mean like you
you're used to smoking weed and you took
meth tonight and and you're on that hot
that high now audience you know and
everybody in the crowd just because you
know too like and again I'm just being
so nerdy about this thing I haven't even
done forever but like an improv audience
watches the show and they're trying to
figure out what's gonna happen next
that's part of part of it great
improvisers can stay a half step ahead
of an audience's they they put the
pieces of the puzzle together before the
audience sees how they fit together by a
beat right and it's that wave that
you're surfing of like you got there and
you got there when they were already
having the thought and you defined how
it was verbalized yes like it's not like
you got there so far ahead that they
went wait huh if you get there at the
exact same moment no titillation you're
surfing and you're at the front of the
wave and they're that curl right like
that's the audience and if you can just
stay just ahead of the curl that's the
best improvisers but a show like that
the crowd was just like I I'm not even I
can I'm not even gonna bother we're not
even gonna bother trying to keep up with
this and that was helpful that was how I
always thought as a teacher and I I
would argue
um as a comedian as a comedian that was
always
kind of there
whenever I buy something I always do my
research especially if it's something
I'm going to ingest inside my body
because doing research before you buy
means making better more informed
choices especially when it comes to
something like a stress or sleep product
like CBD and that's where next Evo
natural is my new favorite CBD brand
knocks it out of the park which isn't
always the case a study by an
independent lab confirmed that some
Brands contain up to 60 percent less CBD
than they claim on the label but with
next Evo you can trust you are getting
the best of the best they use smart sorb
technology trust me if you have tried
CBD in the past and you weren't
impressed give it another go with next
Evo smart sorb is a smart sword has been
proven to have 30 times better
absorption in the first 30 minutes and
four times the overall absorption as
other products and you can tell they're
stress gummies which are CBD and whole
plant ashwagandha are Lifesavers when
I'm feeling overwhelmed or anxious is or
if that stress manifests in my body in
some tight way if I just can't get on
with my day face my inbox handle company
coming over they are my secret weapon to
round the edges and get me back to
feeling ready to face my day if you've
tried it before I swear next Evo is
different gets in fast you know how you
feel so you can dial in the dose and get
it just right upgrade your CBD and show
your support of the show go to
nextevo.com weird to get 20 off your
first order of 40 bucks or more that's
20 off 40 bucks or more at n e x t e v
o.com slash weird this episode is
brought to you by betterhelp getting to
know yourself can be a lifelong process
especially because we're always growing
and changing like before I went to
therapy for real I had no idea what
codependency was or how to end a
relationship in a healthy way or set up
boundaries with family and people I
worked with but that's what therapy is
all about deepening your self-awareness
and your understanding because sometimes
we don't know what we want or why we
react the way we do until we talk things
through with a professional that's what
betterhelp does they connect you with a
licensed therapist who can take you on
that journey of self-discovery from
wherever you are it couldn't be easier
because the more you know about yourself
the more easily you can maneuver through
life with less suffering and more
clarity relationships grief loss anxiety
you name it talking about it with a
professional is greater than the sum of
its parts we always say that on the show
it helps so if you're thinking of
starting therapy give better help a try
it's entirely online convenient flexible
and suited to your schedule just fill
out a brief questionnaire to get matched
with a licensed therapist you can even
switch it anytime for no additional
charge discover your potential with
better help visit
betterhelp.com weirdo today to get 10
off your first month that's better
h-e-l-p
dot com slash weirdo alright everybody
back to Chris
let's talk what's so scary though tell
me was Murph in the rest of the show
and for he sat out a lot of it he was he
was very hurt he was very hurt uh and
then from what I remember the show did
end with the rest of the cast did pick
him up and rotated him on stage oh my
God in a way that was pretty cool yeah
no that's breathtaking yeah it was
pretty artsy fartsy but it was cool we
all just watched a documentary called
Murph dude the Murph documentary murph's
flip
I mean I wish no I'm glad it wasn't
filmed listen I know me too I'm glad it
wasn't filmed but like we did a thing
too so everybody got into that now I'm
just rambling about an old improv class
but
just another Murph story that gives you
a context of who he was at this time and
he's shared this publicly so I don't
think he'll mind I love that you have to
say that because it makes me excited for
the story so we just talked about it
well he all these people got into the
class and then there was like a month or
so before the class started and I was
like well let's not waste time right
then I was like why does the class have
to start on the day the class starts why
does the class have to start in person
so started a big email list and I was
like let's do some assignments and some
of it would be like
bring a thing that has inspired you
artistically we're all going to meet up
and trade them so somebody shows up with
like a Charlie Chaplin DVD set and
somebody shows up with you know this and
blah blah blah and I was participating
in all this because I was like another
arbitrary thing the teacher why does the
teacher not do the thing like yeah like
okay here here's this boxing match that
I really am inspired by I'll give you
that you give me this book it's like
things like that that were almost like a
book club which I thought was very cool
to start the class with and shared such
a thing and then one of them was okay
like
do a thing that's outside of your
comfort zone that you normally wouldn't
do and then write about it and reply all
to this email list and we'll all just
get a sense of each other's Comfort
zones and how you push through that
comfort zone which has major
applications in in the class where
you're learning art
people coming in I remember mine was I
had an afternoon with nothing to do and
I was walking past Penn Station and I
was just like huh supposed to do
something I don't normally do and I just
went to Penn Station looked at which
train was leaving next on the Long
Island Railroad and just bought a ticket
to like Ronkonkoma
and went and
went to that station and there was a bar
and I went and had a soda and then I got
back on the train and it was just like
do something to just disrupt can I the
algorithm of your day I've been thinking
so much we're gonna stay on this I'm not
a long interrupt but I've just been
thinking lately about the value of
disruption yes and it's crucial is huge
crucial I was depressed for like four
days in a row and You're gonna laugh
you're not gonna laugh because you're a
sweet man but like
it might surprise you how stupid the
thing that snapped me out of it was I I
was with my beautiful family doing shows
exercising eating right getting sunlight
meditating reading learning growing
socializing
and what snapped me out of it was and I
already talked about this on we made it
weird but this will be a couple weeks
later was I went on a hundred thousand
dollar pyramid this is what's important
though it wasn't the special boy that's
normally the drug I would do yeah in
that experience I'm a special boy they
have me play games on TV it wasn't that
it was backstage with one of the writers
playing the game just warming up it
wasn't that I was with another celebrity
it was just me and him playing the game
yeah heart jacked sweat like elevated
and I was like oh my God like like
licking a nine volt battery like
something just shocked me yeah and I
came back into my life yeah it by the
way though why that I do cold exposure
it should have been that that's
literally a jolt to your system
sometimes it needs to be some it has to
be a jolt that you're not usually
jolting stand up is the jolt I'm always
jolting when I was horrifically
depressed which has happened a few times
in my life
but in 2007 I started seeing the shrink
that I still see and I remember she said
to me okay one of the first things we're
gonna do she's like uh
so you live in Queens
you got your subway stop right I'm like
yeah she's like how do you walk home and
I'm like well if I take the seven train
I walk I take it to 69th and I walk down
Roosevelt to 67th if I take the e or the
F it goes up to 73rd and I walk down
Roosevelt she goes
this week
never walk that way and never walk the
same way twice yeah and I was like what
do you mean and she's like just even if
it takes five minutes longer ten minutes
longer when you go home
don't walk the same path twice this week
just walk down different blocks yep and
it was
it didn't solve what was a very bad
stretch of depression that led me to
seeing a shrink but all of a sudden
you're like oh there's trees on this
block oh and the leaves are changing
colors and I never walk down this block
so how would I have seen that or like oh
there's a restaurant on this block I've
never eaten here oh that I should eat at
this place I didn't even know this was
this close to my house oh look it's like
a it's like your family you know I lived
in Queens too Colombian family must have
opened this place and I didn't even
notice they opened it I should go
support them I should go try this you
know it's like before you feel it you're
doing it yeah like what a happy person
would do is that so you're doing it and
you're also doing what you want your
brain to do you want your brain like a
grid in Manhattan to form new
connections you're thinking in a way
that's stuck I'm gonna manifest that in
the third dimension like in physical
reality I'm gonna start moving
differently and then the brain mimics it
it's one of those things like walnuts
are really good for your brain walnuts
look like brains like what the [__] is
going on here there's Clues so I was
just thinking about that Reggie Watts
did the show and he was like that was
one of his things he was like drive home
a different way yeah and then I was
thinking about the way that charges move
around your brain we want them to change
it keeps doing this and this is making
me sad pyramid
as arbitrary as that is made it shift
walking home a different way makes it
shift and I was just thinking about that
yesterday morning in the car right
because I I fall into traps too where I
sit here and go okay I just got bad news
about
a contract
how am I going to pay my mortgage I'll
be fine think about it the contract's
still like okay you took a pay cut
but it's not big enough you can still
pay the mortgage you know like okay and
you dwell on a thought like that I have
a kid he's four
pay cut where can we tighten the belt
this and that and I go
sometimes if I go I'm gonna get off I'm
driving home and I'm gonna get off the
highway One Stop earlier and figure out
the local roads I can't sit here and
think about mortgage pay cut kid daycare
cost because right now I have to go
right or left and that's what I need to
deal with right now and that's a simpler
and easier thing and sometimes that can
let me out of mortgage yes kid pay cut
ego shame what did I do wrong you know
yeah sometimes just needing to know oh
wait
this road oh I think I know where I am
okay I have to deal with that now and
it's replaced that thought okay just to
relate I was I have a hot tub I love it
it's a very simple one it's called a
soft tub I recommend it they're not a
sponsor I'm just saying like it's just
it's just a circle it's lightweight
plastic you fill it with water very
low-fi it's hot water I get in it yeah
I'm in it this morning
what am I doing I was taking
what I know our average credit card bill
is in multiplying it by 12.
nice to see just to go like wow that's
how much we spend a year just on the
credit card that's not bills that's not
mortgage that's not all that stuff so
exactly to your point you can be in a
hot tub but if you're
stuck or like get off the highway One
Stop earlier maybe instead of getting in
the hot tub and I actually can agree
with this I should have gone on a walk
and gone a route that I had never gone
before because if the hot tub has fallen
into that level of routine yeah
you've almost developed an immunity to
what it offered you when it when you
first got into it right like you built a
tolerance in the same way you can build
a tolerance to a medication that's right
you've built a tolerance exactly the hot
tub no longer feels so simple and joyous
that it breaks you out of it that's
right
and got in the hot tub you'd be like
this is incredible I gotta get a hot tub
and I'm like interesting you know what I
mean yeah like I have it and sometimes
I'm in there going like times 10 is okay
and then there's two more [__] you know
like this yeah okay so Murph oh Penn
Station Murph I go and take the train
email it out to everybody I got on a
random train I went to a random town in
Long Island I looked around a little bit
the next train back came in 20 minutes
and I spent 20 random minutes in this
town by myself no one knew I went
just had that as a day little thing it's
like breaking the Matrix yeah I was like
they're watching Kristoff and the Truman
shows watching and going what it doesn't
make sense and you're like and there's
other people emailing in you know I
forget the exact examples because this
was in 2000
nine or ten but people saying like I
realized I had a sick day from work so I
just took it I realized I'm it's towards
the end of the year I'm not gonna so I
just took a sick day and I went to a
museum on a work day and I didn't know
and you know people saying that
again Murph who at this point remember
it's before the class we have we have
not met in person yet this is pre-flip
he's a level two student
with an AOL email address
and we only know him as murf we don't
know his real name yeah none of us have
seen him looks like Johnny you know
they're just like people at UCB I used
to live a more Bowery Poetry Club
lifestyle yeah where I knew people I'm
not I'm not judging labeling or
distancing myself from them I just knew
people his name is j-a-w-n-e-e 20. and
that's all I know about all these people
and here we are talking in the green
room I made a lot more I think I made a
lot more sense in that world than I do
in the current my current state of
Engagement with entertainment but we'll
talk more about that later from an
outside perspective disagree we'll get
to it later so murph's email comes in
for this assignment I think it was
assignment like seven or something like
that we did the early ice breakers and
now we're up to number seven and he goes
so
I was really drunk last night and uh
really out of it and I got on the train
and a train was just sitting in the
station it wasn't moving and
I had a lot of whiskey and uh
this woman came up to me and she was
clearly pretty troubled
and she says uh hey uh
do you want to sleep with me for money
and he's like no I'm I'm good thanks so
much and then she went down to one other
end of the train and then I sat there
and I said to myself hold on
assignment seven and I'm reading this
email and I'm like oh no no no no no and
then he basically said that for a few
dollars he said I don't need to get I
don't want to finish but if I give you
five dollars we just like stick a hand
in my pants
and I'm reading it I'm like I am the
teacher of this class and then
immediately it came in and when I I mean
within minutes there were other people
going like hey um
I don't want to feel like I have to
match that bar like this is to and then
he's writing back he's going look
everybody we haven't met yet and you're
gonna learn this is before then no one
had met and he's like you're gonna meet
me and you're gonna learn that if the
assignment is for me to get out of my
comfort zone and do a thing I've never
done I've lived a lot of life like he's
this mystery man and we met him and that
proved very true and but that was one
that I actually went Miyagi with the
hand down his pants dude at that point
will Hines was in charge of the school
and I actually went to will and I said
so a thing happened
and I think you're going to hear about
it and you might need to fire me
he was like the class hasn't started it
hasn't met yet what do you think I was
like so a guy why everything you say
should be followed by a black title card
and it says gravitas pictures like
everything you say with the wine napkin
or Fox Searchlight there you go
everything you say you walk in by
shooting off exactly you walk into an
office and you go Something's Happened I
think you can hear about it and you
might need to fire me gravitas pictures
presents and then but it was true the
flip it's this you're what it is is
it's cosmically gorgeous because it's
true we do live in a very wild our kids
show us as my daughter's four as well
Wild
um when I say reasonless I don't I don't
mean that existentially necessarily I
just mean like we're imposing these
rules podcasts are 90 minutes because TV
used to be 30 minutes to sell
advertisement because we needed to
quantify and we're like two episodes so
there's all this they're all these
assumptions going on it's like John
Draper says you're born alone and you
die alone and they slap a lot of rules
on you to make you forget that but I
never forget yeah that's his mission
statement and it applies to all Society
Pete that's what I'm saying you're
reminding people as the mischievous
Artist as we should be
what do you what are you talking about
we're as I always say we're on a planet
but that's real but we're also members
of awareness we're we're members of a
thing that are aware of each other so
you could think of that as like a field
and we're walking around
and like I understand maybe some people
are get a little uncomfortable with the
hand on the thing what it does for me
like a good performance art is it
reminds me that art can be a naked woman
in a room screaming at a chicken and we
had a I've said this a million times we
had a better sense of that in the 60s
yeah and now when I watch Black Mirror
and stuff and and they have the guy in
the room and every wall of his room is a
scream
and I'm like
you're
are your wonder your potential for
novelty your potential for disruption
your potential to do something that the
Kristoff and the moon watching you on
the fake TV show your ability to disrupt
that is being taken and I don't even
mean this in like a scary way I just
mean it in a literal way we think what's
the problem I'm bored I'll look at my
phone while I take a dump I just told
you I do that sometimes but when you
don't and you let the boredom in
sometimes you remember like it's almost
like waking up from a dream briefly you
go like wait I don't I don't have to be
on this conveyor belt yeah I can get on
the train yeah go to that weird town and
things are tenuous things are tenuous
yeah
even like red lights the only reason
they work is because we all agree to
stop yeah but some Maniac could just
lean on the gas go right through it
that's right and maybe there will be a
big crash
or maybe he'll just go through the
intersection and everything will be fine
yeah that's what New York City thought
I'm trusting my life to this cab driver
and he seems very tired all the time and
we don't realize we're doing like you'll
love this so you're trusting me to a
certain extent obviously you know me
but I'm not trying to scare anybody I'm
actually trying to inspire people
when I've done this on stage a couple
times I remember that go for it I go
people are afraid of flying because they
don't want the airplane to crash but
you're never not in this airplane and I
put my arms out
you are never not in this airplane
yeah and really that's just reminding
you you're an awareness in a vehicle
you're an awareness in a vehicle
and that's not
it should put a oomph in your day when
you go if we're never safe we're always
safe if that makes sense yeah meaning
there's only one level of safeness and
it's the only one there is so don't
worry about it
everything you just said
I
I have started I live in a very small
town in New Jersey now and I've started
volunteering as an ambulance driver
on Tuesday nights yeah this is the most
critical thing I've ever heard it's kind
of my favorite thing I have going in my
life right now inside of my family yeah
it's kind of the thing I get most
excited about the ambulance the
ambulance
and I do it on Tuesday nights but
everything you just said think about
that Pete like there's people
who
they call 9-1-1
when they're in moments of extreme
duress and fear you don't dial 9-1-1
you're when you're on the fence about it
right nobody does yeah people generally
want to avoid calling that if you can
drive yourself to the hospital or your
spouse or something like six grand or
something right like this is a free
service it's a volunteer
but point being like
these people are dialing 9-1-1
and they assume
the people showing up
have some level of authority competence
and competence and look I've been
trained but it's still me it's still the
guy who was on TV with you a couple
years ago blasting the days into our
butts right and I show up today guys
help people imagine if someone like in a
real state looks and goes
I've had this joke on stage someone's
final words are going to be aren't you
the boss from Broad City and it's going
to be so sad when it happens like that's
been my joke and that's how they know
they're going because they're
hallucinating they think that yeah
and that's someone's final words I have
a whole bit about this but look in the
context of this conversation though I
just want to point out to you like when
you're saying
we have this Assumption of safety yeah
it's like no I now participate in a
thing where I know these are very
well-intentioned good-hearted volunteers
who show up because other people need
them yeah and the I'm a driver
it's lower
um commitment like the EMTs certainly do
take classes and they have to re-up but
a lot of them are also retirees yeah
people in their 60s that want to feel
meaning purpose but maybe they're bored
and they're lonely and they're people
right
and it's a social thing you know it's
their social network as much as it is
this thing to help yeah but when you're
having a heart attack it's not their
social network they're showing up with
an AED machine hooking it up to your
chest and electrifying your heart yeah
and
it's made me take a step back and
realize
so much of society
is hanging on by a string like that yeah
and we're convincing ourselves that
there's infrastructure now that's what
uniforms are uniforms are like I'm not a
guy I'm this uniform it's what a judge a
judge wears a robe to and we stand to
because we're co-conspiring to create a
reality this person is fair right and
that reality goes both ways we believe
it so we feel good that there's a judge
and the judge is affected by the rising
as well and his robe as well where's the
judge like
jerked off to some porn he wasn't
expecting to like yesterday you know
what I mean like he was just like Oh I
like that yesterday the judge the guy
who's deciding how long did you go to
jail there's an eye on stage telling me
I'm going to hell and I'm like he's just
some guy yeah he likes soccer
but yeah and I was like he likes soccer
was a line that really stuck in my brain
I really am pretty convinced that we're
perpetually closer
to living in a mad max-like reality and
I'm not a conspiracy theorist
but I'm just like oh
now that I participate in this volunteer
organization that's underfunded that
helps people and I see that people rely
on it and they don't even think
like I think people think we're sitting
at the firehouse waiting for the call
and then the door goes up and we jump in
the ambulance and we get to you it's PAW
Patrol it's like no yeah exactly like
like I'm Chase and it's Chase and Ryder
and uh Marshall yeah
Rocky and Rubble we're both Fighters
but it's no like dude like I'm the EMT
on Tuesday nights if someone in my town
calls I'm not an empty I'm the driver on
Tuesday nights if someone in my town
calls 9-1-1 on a Tuesday night like I'm
home watching Ted lasso with my wife
wow and I throw my pants on Wow and I
run out the door and I drive to the
fires and I get there and that's wait
Society holds in your driveway no the
ambulance is at the firehouse and I have
seven minutes to get there
and if it goes if the pager goes off at
four my shift is 7 P.M till 7am if it
goes off at four in the morning I wake
up and I get out of bed and I'm running
I sleep with my shirt and my socks on
but I throw my pants on and I run to my
car and I'm driving to a firehouse and
there's two EMTs from other Port parts
of town doing the same thing and the
person who called 9-1-1
thought it was PAW Patrol
you assume that those people and in some
places now look in cities it is and
cities these are paid positions but
there's places like Volunteer Fire
squads volunteer ambulances
and soup kitchens and Drug harm
reduction centers and all these places
are just whenever you go to a covet test
that's when it became very clear you're
just some guy you're Shmo you're Ishmael
and God bless you you're trying you're
doing it you're doing more than I can
but you're a schmo's but you are over
there and maybe you went a little too
deep with the progy prong
you're a guy I've been thinking you look
at Reddit too much right you worry too
much about your fantasy football league
you didn't understand
Eternal Sunshine and you're and you're
testing me to see if I have a plague
that might kill me and my family yeah
and that's all of society all the time
it's another way of looking at we're all
in airplanes yeah and what we have is
each other and it's all red lights it's
all red lights it's all a co-conspiring
so be careful what you're Coke inspiring
to create because the good stuff is all
in agreement and the bad stuff is also
an agreement meaning not to get too
metaphysical
this whole thing is a reflection of what
the mind is choosing does that make
sense it does the mind is choosing this
the world looks like that the Mind
chooses this the word looks like that
constant rationalization and just like
you is it my fear of this or is it my
punk rockness I'm the same way and those
are just the issues that we have a
semblance of an idea of what we're doing
yeah like I think it was Freud it might
have been young but it's like the
subconscious is the iceberg like we
don't even know why we do anything yeah
and that's why advertising influencing
all these things work is because it's in
the realm of symbols I read an email I
go to bed I have a dream like you were
in my dream another bit I used to I only
did once but I was like I met Matt Damon
which I think is really funny because
now I might be in his dreams like he
might see me in the streets this is 10
years ago but that's true this is
it's all of it how you do anything's how
you do everything and it's all in
agreement I think about it so much too
and I'm sure you do as well
I look at my kid and I'm like
he just like wakes up and eats and goes
to preschool for a few hours and then
maybe one of the kids in the
neighborhood is playing and they play
outside together
then he comes in and he eats again and
we read a couple of this again and then
he goes to bed
and I'm like dude
he has no idea
that I'm sitting here going
I got a contract reduction on this
project
[Music]
I have these ideas and it seems like I
can't get anybody to buy him what am I
gonna do what if I can't get enough sag
work to get insurance what if I can't do
this do that he has no idea yeah and to
to see
to see someone else who didn't sign up
for my
life with no Foundation yeah he didn't
and when you see a homeless person with
a dog right yeah and you people get mad
probably irrationally if like the dog is
giving the person companionship and
that's probably insanely important but
the instinct is
dog didn't do anything right you
probably did something right yes exactly
you want a scapegoat yeah I'm like oh my
God I am response I am responsible not
just for this kid's welfare
but for not
letting my fear become his fear
I was just saying that to Val I was like
don't parent from your wound because I
was noticing that I was pretty
lackadaisical about Leela meaning
everything will be fine which is which
is good yeah you should have some of
that and probably true and probably true
meaning don't sweat it too much work it
do your best but also have an autopilot
that goes and it'll probably be okay
okay relax
but I also realized that my and I wasn't
neglected as a child but I felt by any
means that's a joke I was hanging with
my mom most of the time and my dad was
home every night you know what I mean it
wasn't brutal and yet there was a
feeling of
the way we pop parent Now sort of the
bluey way yeah big feelings I see you I
understand you really wanted that
raincoat you know all that I think it's
great it wasn't my experience not nor
was it mine nor was it any of us I don't
think but I thrived in that any sort of
not by my choice I think I would have
preferred the bluey way but any sort of
friction or lemon in the water made me
go I started scheming I was like I'm
gonna build a rocket when I was in a
punk band we had a song called Rocket
dream and it was about building a rocket
to leave home and I was like they think
I'm just some person that lives in the
house like ex machina right I'm the
robot in the cage but I'm slowly working
you to be like
okay and I just stole another piece for
the rocket
so I realized that I was parenting a
little bit from my wounds going like
yeah it's great to say Leela will be
okay but am I putting on her like if we
kind of cruise she'll get driven enough
to spite us and build a rock and I was
like that's [__] stupid it's no harm
no foul everything's fine but I
recognized that I was parenting from
what worked for me which might not be
the healthiest choice yeah yeah yeah can
I add go no please from the other thing
that you were saying I've been a lot
more courteous on the road lately and
not not just out of fear although that's
an element to your Mad Max thing
but I was recently visiting I don't want
to out anybody but let's just say people
Beyond people be people are on pills
that you don't know a lot of us I know
there's the opioid crisis but there's
also just people that are using opioids
meaning they're just on
uh drugs
and there are people with guns and I
mean like legal guns and there are
people
with very low IQs that have
guns legal guns so what you made me
think of and again I'm not trying to
propagate fear
I'm just saying we also have an
understanding that people that have guns
and we're seeing that this isn't true
all the time we think that they're in
the PAW Patrol and surely they're they
must be like Obi-Wan Kenobi right
they're like Gandalf who are you to deal
with death they they clearly think
exactly but that's my so look I I can't
solve any big issues not in this
conversation but I'm saying on the road
like on the drive here some dude [__]
veered right in front of me and I I'm a
sarcastic driver meaning I want to get
next to him and be like
like that like a Chandler face yeah not
anymore I stopped before our windows are
even lined up not out of fear it's just
I don't want to even detoxify my own
reality with my vitriol and my anger and
my self-righteousness and I just go if I
was him I'd be him right right and then
right behind that is
it was let's just say I found out
someone I know
far away has a very low IQ and has a gun
and it's legal and I was like you think
they're gonna come out like Denzel
Washington in a movie and they're the
the meditator they're they're clear they
get that Vision like whoa
and like Batman I'll get the penguin
first then Punch The Joker because then
killer crocky's over here it's not that
it might be somebody who isn't very
test test wise intelligent yeah and they
might be on drugs legal drugs right even
if it's an anxiety reducer or something
okay yeah anxiety might be useful in a
situation where you have to decide
life and death so I've just been humbled
in the way you're talking about meaning
don't kid yourself we're all on
airplanes don't kid yourself we only
stop at red lights and don't kid
yourself not everybody with a gun
is is [__] Ghost Dog Samurai you know
what I mean it's it's not the case it's
also like it's a guy named Julian yeah
you know what I mean he there's also a
world too it's like you pull up next to
somebody and you want to make that
sarcastic face because they cut you off
and it's like and we ended up at the
same light I was like you just risk both
our lives and here we are because
there's two things that can happen as
you make the face and they either feel
shame or give you the finger yeah and
then you both drive away it either ends
where you both drive away or any other
way that it ends yeah it's not a way you
want it to end that's right there's one
way where everybody drives away but you
got that in yep any other and do you
really need to win it at the buffet my
friend Nate Craig has a joke when you
lose in Vegas don't win it at the buffet
don't win it back at the buffet Val and
I say don't win it back at the buffet
almost every day I've texted Nate this I
it's a bit that just filled a gap in my
life you lost you got scared someone cut
in front of you two lanes in front of me
I had to hit the brakes scary you got
scared you so you lost the casino
don't want it back at the buffet don't
pull up to him and be like yee why
you're risking so much I do have some
moments that come to mind from growing
up in New Jersey where those were some
of the most validating moments of my
life dude I was in a car with somebody
from New Jersey press Prescott tolk is
his name we were in Chicago
and
we stopped a stop sign and these people
were crossing in front of us and then
when they stopped they were like they
were kind of like drunk kids and they're
like you can go now
and uh Prescott threw it in park got out
of the car and was like oh I can go now
it's okay for me to go yeah Jersey
people are yeah we're crazy with that
like oh thank you thank you for letting
me know I can go like five dudes and I
was like
what what is that you know that I have I
ever told you that I like me the me you
know yeah once knowingly started a
high-speed police chase on a highway
gravitas pictures presents
have I told you that no yeah
when I was in college what someone's
driving I had uh
12 points on my license I think because
I had speeding tickets and accidents
and uh I think it was I think it was
whatever number it was it was one away
from losing my license if I got one more
point on my license I would not have a
license which would have been a disaster
needed it to get back and forth to
school and work and things and I was
driving on Route 287 in New Jersey and I
was flying it was the middle of the
night and this was that stretch in my
life where it was like
I was a full-time college student
I worked three days a week at a magazine
and packed in pretty much 40 hours in
three days so I could also go to school
and I had already started at UCB because
I started there when I was ended my
sophomore year in college
so I was like never sleeping it was
stupid burning myself down full-time
college student full-time job and going
into the city to do comedy as often as I
could and I was driving and I was
exhausted and I was doing like 90
something
around 90 probably and I saw the
headlights flick on on the center medium
and that's only a cop you know yeah but
I was going so fast
I keep going and then a few seconds
later I look and I see that the lights
pull out and the cars behind me
and I'm like that has to be a cop car
but he hasn't turned on his Sirens yet I
was pulled over two days ago that's
that's a that's a thing there's always
the moment where you're like what's
happening oh where's that now I react I
think that's when they're calling it in
I think so yeah so he I go he hasn't
turned on the lights and siren yet
there I can see the next exit and I went
I'll [__] make it to that and I hit
the gas
and I said let me get to that goddamn
exit and he he I he started accelerating
but he still didn't turn on the lights
and I mean you wanted to see where this
goes but let me also say she just became
a bigger fish you've known me in some
stretches where I was more unhinged
you've seen it you've been around we've
been in each other's sphere and this was
before I had any treatment this was in a
stretch of life before I had any this
was not this was just the state of my
life like you and I have known each
other long enough that there's been a
few times where it's been like
oh I like
gethers acting crazy you know like and
that's been a word that spread because
things broke again this was when that
was just the state of being so I was
like you went back to how you were this
is when you were this was when I were
yeah this is when I were this is when I
was that so in my head I was just like
as long as he doesn't turn on the lights
I'm gonna just go for it and I made it
to an exit
and uh got off the highway
and it was a big looping exit so I could
see when I was like two-thirds of the
way up I could see the headlights that
he was also taking the exit and it was
some area of New Jersey that I didn't
know well dude here's the best part
these uh so I go I took a few random
turns off this exit and wound up in this
neighborhood and turned off all the
lights in the car and then like got down
like drive like yeah like total darkness
and then I was sitting there and I was
down there and I was like
the [__] am I doing like it was only
then that I was like what the [__] then
I kind of poked my head up and I could
tell it was a very like the houses were
really wealthy I was like these people
are gonna call the [__] what am I
doing like what did I just holy [__]
what did I just do you know I was really
scared so I waited a few minutes I was
like I gotta get out of here I love that
there's a cop siren yeah
but in my head I was just like you know
okay I've learned my lesson on this and
um
I
get back to the exit to get back on the
highway and the cop was just waiting
there
and he pulled me over he knew at some
point I was gonna have to get back to
the highway
will you stop when you're talking to me
he pulled me over
you ate where his lights off because in
the movie gravitas pictures but you know
he turned him on and they come on and
you're like I was like there he is [__]
and he was pissed real pissed how could
he be sure
he you got your license I don't know
sure yeah maybe but either way he walked
up he's like licensed registration
insurance now
I get my license out of my wallet I give
him the license I opened up my glove
compartment
and I just was like sir
I'm so sorry to tell you this
I can't I I don't know where my
registration and insurance are and he's
like you have to be [__] kidding he's
like after all you don't I was like
they're not they should be in there
I don't see them
I'm very sorry about that
and then he looks at my license of
course it's like Mr get hard do you know
why I'm pulling you over he said get
hard said get hard didn't correct him
and um
Mr get hurt he goes
uh easy
tell he's like you know you're going so
fast it's so unsafe he's like do you
have any points on your license already
I was like yeah if I lose
uh if I lose if I get one more if I go
if I go one more I'm gonna lose my
license he's like are you [__]
serious like every step of the way he's
like you [__] kidding me right
and then he looks at my license and he
goes uh
he goes uh I'll never forget he goes
so it says here you live in West Orange
I go yeah I'm going to my parents house
in West Orange
and he goes but this exit does not get
you to West Orange and I go no it does
not
and he goes so I am safe then and
assuming the only reason you got off at
this exit was to evade capture by me
and I heard that and I'm like that's
like jail evading arrest you know and I
just looked at him and I I was I just go
uh you know I'm gonna be honest sir yeah
I was evading capture by you
and um I just want you to know that I'm
aware it's it's by far the stupidest
thing I've ever done
and to this day I don't know why he just
looked at me and he's like you know what
man
have a good night and he just gave me
the license back and all first of all
are you when people say White Privilege
isn't real I'm like oh no I've lived it
right there I've lived first of all but
secondly I'm like all I could ever think
of Pete was like I think he legitimately
realized that I was I think at that I
think I was 20 and I think he was like
this is a 20 year old kid
and this will actually ruin his life
like it will actually
he's gonna go to jail for e-rating
evading arrest from a State Trooper
driving without most of his
documentation going 30 miles above the
speed limit with 12 points on his
license like
kids it's gonna ruin his life but it's
all like all I've I've never totally
been sure but that's all I can think of
that's the only reason yeah unless in
that moment he had a vision of you on a
bidet in front of a studio audience this
guy is going to do some some
um
some alternative he's going to do some
alternative comedy someday that's
beloved by a small But Mighty yes fan
base
the get heads yeah yeah the get-heads
yeah that name didn't Angela
as you know oh my God this microphone is
moist I just every story you tell I'm
freaking out and it was bad it was it
was really dumb I got pulled over two
days ago and again I I felt for no
reason he just dropped the number of
uh miles over I was going just to help
you out a little bit yeah and I was but
I also been pulled over not that long
ago and it was the opposite the guy was
very curtain and this guy was just kind
of like he's telling me stories did not
recognize me all I said to Val was I was
in I was happy speeding I was on the
phone with a friend just having a great
day because my depression had broken
yeah I was cruising yeah I wasn't
driving dangerous I was going too fast
love it and I swear this is my but this
is what we do we build a story the story
that I do not think is literally true
but I'm still going to tell you is that
I was a beam of light I was like did you
tell the officer that no but as soon as
he talked to me and I'm just like
immediately admitted fault immediately
like anything I could do to just like I
was just like happy to see him like
there was no he I had a Mountain Valley
Spring bottle and he thought it was a
beer bottle and I was like oh yeah we're
having like a little moment he was like
you'd be surprised and it's like this is
[__] privilege for sure yeah I can
see that and I'm a little embarrassed
and shamed but I'm also just like
I love this guy in the story I love this
guy that he decided not he had you yeah
he was past too but he got past it I
went I got out of a ticket back then too
once when I was a kid because I was so
scared that I kept calling The copier
honor he's like do you know you were
speeding and I was like I know I'm
really sorry about that your honor and
he's like that's what you call a judge
he's like I'm an officer and my response
was I'm uh sorry about that your honor
and he laughed so hard and he was like
you know what just kick you out you get
out of here just go
you I don't know what I mean I think I
just mean you're likable and people root
for you you have a get out of here face
I I think I have a
you're not the guy I in a movie you
would never get cast as the guy that
gets the book thrown at him I don't
think so but and I think especially back
then there may have been some sense that
maybe some of these people were like
this kid seems stressed out enough you
know like this kid seems like he's
pretty well that's what I'm getting what
do we what are we aware of that we don't
know we're aware of yeah and in that
moment he was listening to a gut or
something yeah and that's what again I
can't know this is true and if I had to
bet like is it true I'd say no but I'm
like this guy's picking up that he is
pulled over a guy that made a mistake
and nobody got hurt in the process yes
and is is has been driving more slowly
and more safely and it was like I can't
call it but interesting any ambulance
stories oh so many
it's the best it's the best I mean so
first of all most you sleep well on
those nights
um initially I didn't initially it was
quite hard uh but now I do I mean
because it's such a small town like to
put in perspective I work Tuesday nights
there was one stretch where we didn't
get a call on a Tuesday night for nine
weeks oh well so it's this is not like a
procedural where I'm flying out the door
yeah yeah you know
um but yeah uh you know it's a very
good-hearted thing to do all the people
involved are I I really admire them
most of it
is helping elderly people that's been a
very eye-opening thing
um excuse me one moment I have to sneeze
bless you thank you I can't help but
notice you sneezed over there but your
parents live in West Orange there you go
weird a thrift you sneezed in that
direction
um I've had I was just gonna say my mom
is older now getting older and they're
both in their 80s and I'm just like
these people it's a weird combo of need
help and won't ask or admit that they
need help and then there's a lot of so
there's an app on my phone and you get
all the alerts in town even if you're
not on duty because there are situations
where
let's say there's already been a call
and one the crew on duty is out yeah and
then another call comes in well now you
need to scramble and if you're around go
wow you know it's like that type of
thing so you see all the alerts all the
time
and most of them are false most of them
are an elderly person fell or an elderly
person's medical bracelet went off and
we can't get in touch with them and we
need you to go check on it or
you know a pre-existing condition and
you're giving a person a ride to the
hospital because their spouse is also in
their 80s and they can't drive at night
so can you give them a ride it's very
simple stuff but yeah the ones that
aren't simple I can say I've had I've
now done I've been doing it a year
I've had about 30 calls
can I ask real quick yeah why did you
sign up for life
I think
to help for life my wife we gotta they
put a note in the mailbox that was like
hey we need volunteers think about
signing up and my wife was like I think
you'd be good at this like you're pretty
good I'm strip for a guy who's been
riddled by anxiety one thing that
anxiety people I think will tell you is
very often we're actually very good
Under Pressure yeah because we live in
that headspace right the problem is we
live in it when it's not warranted or
real that's right so that's called our
dry run but in an emergency there's a
lot of people going what is this feeling
I haven't and I'm like this is welcome
to this is my comfort zone this is why
I'm so annoying at parties yeah that's
right that's right um so I'm actually
she's like you're a really good driver
you're good under pressure and I signed
up and it takes a little more time than
we anticipated
um but I really like it I like helping I
like finding small ways to help them I
used to think that I could make comedy
that gave people who needed something
those things
and I think in those days that was true
like I you know my HBO special was about
depression and suicide and stuff and
people have told me to help them and the
old gethard show a lot of the people who
watched it say it helped them when they
were younger and they needed it but I
don't know that my comedy at least right
now
it has that potential as much I don't
know if I'm as relevant as someone
in that space
I think I've a lot of the things that I
had to fire I think I went and fought
those fights and I had and and now
there's other people with fights and I
don't want to take up the oxygen in that
room and I've had to take a deep breath
and be okay with that but now I realize
like oh that feeling of helping people
through my comedy
you can just help people
in a way that's meant to help people and
you still get that satisfaction even if
you don't get the ego and the cheers and
the laughs and the camaraderie with the
other I'm still helping people and that
that particular dopamine is just there
for the taking for anyone like I promise
you wherever you live there's some place
nearby you could be volunteering and
you'll feel good doing it you know yeah
um it's one of the biggest secrets of
life I haven't yet I delude myself and
I'm like well my comedy helps people in
the podcast help people I think that's
true I don't know if my brain knows it
as well as it would know it as driving
someone on a gurney right and I learned
that lesson I kind of signed signed up
pandemic boredom moved to a new town
my wife was like why don't you do this
shake things up and it's actually been
very gratifying
um I've had only a couple
that were scary
um
I'm not allowed to say too much because
of HIPAA laws about specifics but like
I've never seen someone die I I have had
someone in my ambulance who I later
learned died and I saw them in that
process and that was extremely sobering
um
[Music]
um I can say that there have been a
number of weird and funny ones that make
it completely worth it
oh you can't I can't I can I can't say
anything that would identify someone I
can tell you that I once
you get that the app goes off
and you also have a separate pager so
that if one isn't working and that
starts going
to EMS EMS
this voiceover so you can't sleep
through this you know and when the app
goes off on my phone it first it gives
you a one sentence description then the
911 dispatcher is updating it as they
learn information so the very first
thing is it goes off and you see one
sentence like I said it'll say fall
it'll say diabetic issue asthma attack
these things where you go okay these
things happen this is really framing
when I was a kid we called 9-1-1 in a
sketch we were shooting and it was an ad
for 9-1-1 I went 9-1-1 it's always free
and we hung up and they heard I can't
breathe so thinking about the people
with beepers and it goes off someone
can't breathe and they're really hauling
and they probably heard that it was like
a younger person's voice yeah which is
terrifying a younger person with a
breathing issue something's really wrong
and when I and they got there I'm doing
bits and stuff you're like oh sorry
about that so they're usually these
simple things sobering it goes off at
about 11 at night
and it says uh I'll tell you this one
first
the first night I drove on my own and to
give you a sense of how volunteerism
Works in America
I was shadowing the guy on Tuesday
nights and I had I had I had gone and
gotten my CPR certification
one of the drivers who's been around a
long time took me out during the day and
I drove the ambulance four or five times
and then there were three weeks in a row
on Tuesdays where I shadowed this other
driver and I shadowed him on I think two
or three calls
and then one night uh or one Tuesday
during the day the captain of the first
aid Squad texted me and he goes hey so
just so you know you're bumped up you're
no longer trainee you're the Tuesday
night driver now and I wrote back and I
said I've only shadowed him a few weeks
I don't know if I'm ready yet and his
response was that guy moved you're the
Tuesday night guide and that tells you a
lot about volunteerism you know it
really does like no younger Generations
are not stepping up yeah I moved he
doesn't live in town anymore you're the
Tuesday night guy so my first night we
had one call that was a guy with a heart
issue but he was fine and he was talking
and he just needed a ride and it was a
pre-existing thing I said okay got my
first one under the way that was about
like eight or nine o'clock
I'm leaving the house Hallie's going
baby be careful I love you good job like
it was all this adrenaline
same night 2 30 in the morning
it wakes us up hell he's like holy [__]
I run out of the house throwing my pants
on and I look at the app and it just
says man and ditch and I'm like here we
go and I live in a town that's uh pretty
like I spent all my TV show money on it
I wouldn't say that I don't have tons of
money coming in anymore but I had a few
years there whereas now I can buy a
house and I'm living in a town that's
you know it's a wealthier zip code
really quiet at night it doesn't really
have a downtown with businesses
there's no reason for somebody walking
around at 2 30 at night we get out there
and this guy is in a ditch and he's
there and there's a cop there and the
guy's bleeding he's got blood counters
head and his ankles busted
and um my crew chief gets out and she's
like okay so you know what happened he's
like I fell in the ditch she's like what
were you doing out here it's the middle
of nowhere like P I'm telling you I live
in a Suburban neighborhood but when you
get to the end of my block it's woods
and Farms like it's the end of the
suburbs and the beginning of farm
country in New Jersey like legitimately
my neighborhood is like the last suburb
before this other stretch
she's like what are you doing walking
around here in the first place at this
time of night and he's like well I went
out drinking with friends in Morristown
and I didn't want to drive because I
have a DUI so I took a train
um and I'm too drunk and I didn't really
I missed the last train so I figured I'd
just walk home
and we asked where he's walking to he
tells us where he lives and it's like an
a solid hour drive and we're like you're
gonna walk it in the middle of the night
in a town with no street lights she's
like okay
why didn't you call one of your friends
to come pick you up he's like I guess I
just didn't have
friends that I think would do that and
let me also be clear he's speaking like
I'm speaking now he's not drunk I'm
looking at him and I'm like I've been
drunk in my life it's been many years
but I have been drunk and I've been
around drunk people this person's not
drunk we could immediately sense
something's up she's like why don't you
call somebody I guess none of my friends
would do that
she goes why didn't you get like an Uber
or a lift he's like I don't I don't have
those apps on my phone
she's like why didn't she download them
he goes well I wasn't getting reception
she goes but you called us
and then everybody just stopped and was
staring at each other and it was just
like
what is happening here and the guy
didn't want to get back in the ambulance
and the cop was like you get in the
[__] like I'm not like if you wander
around limping and bleeding through this
town at three in the morning I'm gonna
get eight more calls about you buddy
like you can barely walk get in the
ambulance we take him to the hospital
he's like I don't want to go in we're
like get in like we're not spending all
night doing this and
my the crew that was there that night we
have debated ever since
what was really going on yeah like what
he was so clearly lying
some people were like I think he might
have been on other drugs besides booze
and didn't want to admit it like maybe
he was on shrooms or something or acid
yeah I was like I bet he was hooking up
with somebody
and he like went for a kink and they
were like you got to get the [__] out of
my house like I bet he came back to my
town with somebody
and then he was like you would want me
to pee on you and they were like you
gotta go and he then he had to walk I
think it was something like that you
know that's like he was like I don't
even have time to call an Uber because
I'm ashamed I gotta go right I go right
to Crime though I think so I did a crime
that there was something so clearly
going on yeah
I had another one where there was a it
came up it was like 11 o'clock flipped
car I was like [__] this is for Real
this is really for real this is the
vehicle version of man and ditch there
you go and uh I get there
dude I pull up there's like
10 fire trucks from all different nearby
towns
cop cars
turns out this dude had stolen a car and
tried to rob a restaurant the next town
over and then fled and flipped his car
wow
Carr was accordioned he was fine which
my crew chief said that only happens
when someone's really drunk or [__] up
because their body they don't their body
stays relaxed tens bodies get injured
tense bodies get injured and they don't
tense up this kid was fine I looked at
the car I said I'm about to see a dead
body and instead the kid was fine yeah
now he claimed that there were other
people in the car that ran away which I
think turned out to not be true but they
had canine units they had drones in the
sky and I pull up in the image me Pete
me like the guy you've known forever
me on a TV show would all assume this
guy lives at a hospital dude yeah but
like the impact guy like the guy who
tells the long emo stories you know yeah
and they're like you gotta back it in
back in it so I'm like backing up
between like dogs and drones and fire
trucks I'm like what the [__] is going
what's going on tonight the captain of
the crew was with us I think he's like
you need me to get out I'm like no I I
got it he's like all right Young Buck
like this is pretty good [__] for a
rookie I'm like what the [__] is
happening here he said that dude they
put him in the stretcher in our
ambulance they handcuffed him there's a
cop on board of them and he's rambling
because he's high on who knows what and
the cops are like you can't go yet we
gotta write down what he's saying and it
was really intense eventually we're on
our way to the hospital
and he's been rambling this whole time
and he just goes silent and you feel
everybody perks up to listen
and he just I don't know where this goes
whoa
I could have [__] died back there and
I've never laughed harder
what a punchline for me to come upon the
scene with like a dozen fire trucks and
dogs and drones and angry cops and
handcuffs and he's rambling because he's
it seemed like on amphetamines or
something and then silence whoa I could
have [__] died back there I was like
that is who's got better timing than
that you are the first and only guest
that answer a new question since you've
been on the show last is when's the time
you laughed hardest and you just
answered
that was probably it without me asking
speaking of which when is your flight I
don't want you to miss it oh I should
probably go to the airport
oh my flight's at two you're fine
you're fine I'm gonna trust the person
who's telling me I'm not fine
you're absolutely fine how long does it
take to get to the airport 45 minutes
but it's Los Angeles what do you mean
what do you mean what do I I've spent
I've been here for three days and I've
spent the entirety of it sitting in
traffic okay watch this okay this is
good this is good podcasting
yeah nobody's going to the well that's
that's true okay it says I'm gonna turn
my phone off airplane mode and if it
starts highly beeping that means a 9-1-1
call has happened in my town in New
Jersey since we've been doing this
and Pete I follow the app it says 49
minutes
I travel for 11 folks but that'll get me
there at one
before your flight let me double check
when the is this an international flight
no it's to Chicago okay and flights
no I'm driving I have to drop my rental
car I was gonna call you an Uber I want
the credit for being nice
um Pete this is the app
and I can't show you specifics but like
this these are the people who have
listed themselves as off duty which
means they're out of 10. I could do that
technically now if I'm in town I leave
it I always leave it on because this is
it's like um
I don't want to say It's Entertainment
it's not I understand police scanner
it's the police scanner thing of mine
and I also know you're this close to
being Spider-Man like it went off last
night with a really Grim sounding call
and I'm like oh I know the people on the
crew tonight and I'm watching it to be
like are they getting are they getting
there in time like and you can see like
it comes in with the wow I can't show
you too much of this but like all these
updates in this code no there's a
picture of the guy's dick that's not
that's weird he sent a dick pic right
before this emergency I don't know why
the 911 operator included that let's but
I sit there and I'm updated and I'm like
okay like all right good they're at the
Station House like these time codes that
you don't know what they mean like
that's when they got dispatched that's
when they got to the Station House
that's when they actually left that's
when they got to this good numbers guys
and I I track it and I'm like okay okay
okay oh great they got there good good
good good good good it's crazy man I'm
so it feels so perfect
and I can't wait to see the gravitas
picture Murph flip and Jersey I can't
believe how hard we laughed about that
Murph flip it was so good I knew you'd
like that I didn't but I haven't thought
about it I loved it
but I also it's also funny too because
it's a side of improv where I'm like
they did that show I don't know if I I
probably would have had it but most of
us
if there's an audience there you don't
want to scare them you want to please
them yeah and they were scared that
night I get it and I love it I get it
you you're an incredible guy I this was
such a great episode I was really it's
always good to talk to you I know and I
knew it would be wonderful but I didn't
expect it to be this wonderful and
you're a real gift thank you and we've
always connected and there have been as
mentioned on the show before a few times
where
I feel like we've we had a friendship
years ago I would say that friendship
still maintains but entertainment drags
people apart yeah and in spite of that
there have been a few times where we've
crossed paths either in person or via
reaching out where I'm like oh Pete's
always been down to step up as a friend
and it means a lot to me oh I feel the
same way about you I'm embarrassed to
say this but I think you'll understand I
have a file in my phone called friends
and it's just I just I need to write
them down because sometimes the stupid
life you forget very easy to see there
it is Chris gethard I go oh yeah I did
on the way in today I was feeling kind
of existentially scared and there are
people that I call yeah and it's really
nice that you're one of them I love you
yeah you've stepped up a few times and
I'll say this we were talking before
about like do you feel disappointment
mentor and there's times where I go not
everybody does step up even people
you've been
through very intense close stretches
with oh not every that's what was going
to get dark yeah yeah and I don't want
to get dark to end it but just I I say
it as a positive in appreciation of you
of
there have been times where
we've been in the same city for you know
Montreal yeah where I remember us having
a conversation that meant so much to me
right you know like times where you've
picked up a phone or times where I've
picked your advice and a couple times
when I remember you once there was one
time when I won't say what but like I
think you needed someone with some punk
rock ethics and you were like should
here's that thing I'm wondering what's
your instinct on and I go I know why
Pete's asking me about this and I know
yeah no here's
get out of your own way on this you know
and it means a lot to me that we can do
that to each other even though it's once
every couple years I agree it's an
important thing yeah it's almost it
might not be literally true but it's
like a like past life people that keep
coming and like we found each other
again yeah and I have friends in
Montreal you see them on a marquee and
you text them and you don't hear back
but I'm not getting dark and I
understand if I was that much but it's
hard it's heartbreaking it's
heartbreaking it can still be sad and we
can understand and have compassion
because I sometimes on my dark days feel
like oh I fooled myself into thinking
that we were part of a movement together
yeah and I guess for you it wasn't that
and it took me a long time to realize
that's fine too yeah you're allowed to
not be motivated by that right my
motivation was that especially with the
old TV show you know but some people
when it got canceled
moved on yeah we're not tight anymore
right and for a long time I felt like
what did I do wrong and I realized no we
came together for the thing it's man on
wire I just re-watched man on wire did
you watch that I haven't seen it in
years is that Philippe petite yeah
there's a great children's book about
him my son is obsessed with Philippe
Petit because of this children's book
but I haven't rewatched the
documentation there's just a moment
where one of the guys that secured the
wire on the World Trade Center before he
walked across it is just talking about
how important it was and clearly they
fell out of touch as soon as it was
ended and he just starts crying and they
it's such restraint in the documentary
they don't ask him why are he crying
like what are you feeling right now they
just let him cry and you go I know why
he's crying this changed his life and he
doesn't see this person right and that
part is over I've I've had that I've had
that feeling in a big way of like oh I
did some stuff that I know changed my
life yeah well you are a petite Philippe
and your son is going to be thrilled as
he starts to piece this together or
people on the schoolyard will make fun
of him when they're like your dad went
on TV and put a bidet in his [__]
I've had that thought too but ultimately
I think he's gonna realize I think
they're gonna be and my mom watching an
AI movie made about them starring them
for them
like I've lived a pretty cool wife life
and my wife has lived one that makes me
look [__] lame so he's gonna at some
point realize
that uh his parents walked the walk and
walked the wire there you go there it is
would you say keep it crispy I'm only
rushing because I got to get you out
keep it yeah absolutely keep it crispy
why would you not keep it crispy
thank you my my friend you're the best
Pete you're the best that was so
incredible
[Music]